So it's probably worth touching upon the file structure of Unreal Engine just to get yourself
familiar with how Unreal handles different files and folder structures.
So we'll go over projects and templates to show you how to set them up.
I will also talk about the files and folders and then the overall structure of your projects
to give you a better understanding.
So first off, tackling projects and templates.
So we have our project browser here where you open the projects.
You'll always start a new project from this location.
And so essentially what we have is you can see the different tabs on the left hand of
the image.
So you have recent projects, games, film, video, live events, architecture and automotive.
And these are almost different presets that you can select that give you some prerequisite
information on your projects and how to use different features and functionality.
It is to say that if you select one project type over the other and wish to change, you
can do that inside the engine.
However, some of the default configurations will be different and you'd have to go through
and change them all.
So it's not to say that it can't be done, but it's probably an easier starting point
to pick the relevant prefab here.
And then you have a series of projects that you can choose from depending on the different
topic area.
So maybe you just want a blank project that has none of the content in.
Maybe you want some kind of different preset setup so you can get straight into the work
that you want to create.
And then you can do that through the different configurations here.
It's also worth noting that just give yourself a good project name in the bottom right so
that instead of my project, it's named something you'll remember later.
It's always good to save the project location on an SSD drive if you have that to hand because
that's going to be the fastest way to access Unreal Engine.
When talking about project files, so essentially if we go over the traditional app workflow
here, we have our software and we save a scene.
Maybe it's in Maya, so we save the scene as a Maya binary file and then it just saves
as a single file.
So whether you're using Photoshop or Word or Maya, each one has a kind of relevant file
naming system.
So Photoshop or PSDs, Word, doc files, and then Maya, Maya binary files.
And that's how a traditional app would save to visualize your scene inside of the relevant
software.
In Unreal Engine, all assets are imported, whether that be models, textures, audio, animations,
they're all stored in a content folder as UAsset.
So UAsset just means a real asset and they're all stored as individual files that you can
access.
Levels are saved as UMaps, so the scenes that you are creating are called UMaps, Unreal
Maps, and then the projects are saved as UProjects.
And we'll go over this in a second in terms of the hierarchy here, but they're useful
things to just consider for now.
So if we're looking at the Unreal Engine section, we have the level editor, we have the asset
editor, we have a material editor, and each time you save a file, it will go to its relevant
Unreal Assets.
If you're using the level editor, you've got a Maya level.
If you're using the assets, it's Maya model, or maybe a material, Maya material.
And again, you change these naming conventions, but essentially you're seeing the asset extension,
so UAsset or UMap.
So that's a useful thing to consider here.
Again, when you're using Maya or Photoshop, you'd export from Maya to an FBX, and then
the FBX comes into Unreal still as a UAsset.
Even though you export it as an FBX, it'll turn into a UAsset.
Same with PNGs or PSDs or anything like this.
They'll, well, PSDs won't import, but PNG will go in as a UAsset.
So then talking about the folder structure, where all your files are stored, you'll see
that we've scrolled to our Unreal Projects section in our Documents folder, which is
the default location.
You may have picked a different location, but you'll see there's a config folder, content,
intermediate, saved, and then the UProject.
So the UProject is this blue icon that you'll always double-click to open your project.
And so this will house all the information above, and the UProject is more of a director
to access all these files.
Going through step by step, the config folder stores, as you'd expect, all your configurations
of your project.
So if you've changed any settings in the engine, whether it be project settings or engine settings,
maybe you've set up certain inputs for your projects, they'll all be housed in the config.
And you can access these directly from the engine, but the files are stored in the config
folder.
Content is where all the assets are being stored that we were referring to on the previous
slide.
So whether that be animations or models or textures or anything like this, they're all
stored in your content folder.
The intermediate and saved folders, the intermediate is more of a cached folder.
You don't have to take this with you to make your projects work.
Sometimes it can be a lot of gigabytes of information.
And if you didn't copy this across and you only had your config and content folder plus
your UProject, your UProject would likely load.
The saved folder, however, has maybe some saved data in there that you need.
Maybe it's only got auto saves, but if you have exported any movies or you have saved
any screenshots directly from the engine, all this saved information will go into the
saved folder.
So your actual saved files, your saved maps, they are all in the content folder.
Like the main bits of content is still in the content folder.
Saved is just for if you've exported anything from the engine and you've not moved it out
of that directory.
So just make sure you don't lose any information there.
Again, if it's only auto save data, then you don't necessarily need it for the project
to run.
So, and then you can see the windows of the materials and meshes folder.
So you can see that they're essentially all just UAssets at this point.
So for the naming convention, we do M underscore for a material, which you see in the middle
window there.
And at the bottom window, you see SM underscore, which just means static mesh underscore, and
then you'll see all the meshes.
So essentially, you can see the folder structure and you can see all the individual assets
listed there, which is a really useful viewer, but they're all UAssets.
So they're not their FBX exports or whatever you might have exported these files as.
So it's just useful to consider those.
And then the folder structure, the project structure, sorry.
So the project, that blue icon, the U project that we showed you in the previous slide,
that houses all of this information.
So the project is a container.
It's almost like a wrapper for everything that goes on inside the project.
So then you'll have levels stored where the scenes that you open that you use to edit
the content that you've got in those levels and then act as all the individual assets,
whether they be audio files, animations, static meshes, they're all actors placed in the scene.
So that's just hopefully a useful representation of the project structure and a useful overview
of how the files and projects work.